all right we're gonna keep the country
music theme going with mr luke bryan
last night his proud to be right here
tour stopped in bangor maine and tonight
guilford new hampshire luke telling me
he is loving being back on stage
how is it again to be back on the road
i'm so blessed because i look out there
and places are still sold out and people
want to come see me live and
the day that i wake up and i look out
there and there's empty seats and stuff
i'm like well
maybe i ought to start trying another
avenue in entertainment maybe in five
years i might be a high school football
coach or something you know who knows
well luke's going to have to put those
plans on hold the 45 year old just sold
out nashville's bridgestone arena while
on a 36 show tour
across the country this week he
announced he's back for season 20 of
american idol
and in february he kicks off a nine show
run in vegas
if offered the opportunity to do
broadway would you
you know i'm always i would always keep
options open for everything i mean my
only thing is
if i ever dive into that stuff i really
want to be able to focus
but i would never say no to any of the
ride opportunities
but i mean the problem with me it's not
a problem i mean my touring life
it's still so amazing you can multitask
honey you can do it
well you you run that by carolina let me
know how that goes
[Music]
well broadway really isn't that much of
a stretch for luke who got his start
singing in high school musicals
this never before seen home video is
part of luke's new five-part docu-series
my dirt road diary which premiered today
on imdb
tv they wanted luke to sing and
entertain he enjoyed it
how much convincing did you have to do
for those family and friends to sit down
and talk about you well a lot of my
family and friends you know
they they're not uh they're not short on
short on words
[Music]